I'm not allowed to climb this tower.
I did ask, but not only does climbing this
need proper training and safety equipment,
it's also a protected historic site.
The folks in charge are
understandably a bit cautious.
But while I can't go up there...
the camera and you can.
This is a moonlight tower
here in Austin, Texas,
and it's one of the last surviving
municipal lighting towers anywhere,
because if you're lighting up a city
to keep people safe at night,
why have thousands of small lamps
down every street
when you could have just a few,
very bright and very high?
- Each tower was intended to provide light
equal to that of natural moonlight
in an area 1500 feet
from the base of the tower,
and that is light by which somebody could
read the face of their watch.
These lighting systems were
all throughout the Midwest
and all throughout the west.
- When these towers
were installed in 1894,
they used carbon arc lamps,
the first practical electric lights.
Those lamps were literally
controlled electrical arcing,
a constant spark shooting through the air
between two carbon electrodes.
These days, if you're seeing that kind of
harsh white light at this scale,
it's usually because there's a fault
with something big and electrical
and there's a short in the system.
This was the same effect, just deliberate.
The catch is that the
electrodes on carbon arc lamps
are steadily vaporized, wearing down
as they're worn away by the spark,
so they burn out quickly.
And the city had to pay someone
to climb every tower every day
to replace the lamps.
- The City of Austin Electric Utility,
and as we know it today, Austin Energy,
started with the moonlight towers.
Every night, a utility employee
would go up
through this elevator pulley system
through the middle of the tower
and go light these carbon arc lamps.
This pulley system,
there's this little thing
for the employee to stand in,
and then you have workers on the ground
who are hoisting him up.
You're going up potentially
165 feet in the air.
I don't know when hard hats
came into play,
but when you look at
older pictures,
our safety equipment
is not as it is today.
So then in the 1920s, they
switched to incandescent bulbs,
and in 1936 it was the
mercury vapor lamps,
and today we're using LED bulbs,
and it's a little bit
easier to get up there
and exchange the parts.
So we're using cranes and bucket trucks
to get up to make those changes.
- If ever there was a subject
designed for vertical
video, it's this one.
Most cities took their towers down
as electric street lighting
became possible.
For some unknown reason,
Austin never got round to it,
but they've not all been preserved.
There's only about a dozen
towers still standing.
Not all of those are in the
same locations they used to be.
And in 1993, the city took them all apart,
refurbished them, and
put them back up again.
As for what they look like
when they're switched on,
well, for that, we'll need
to wait until after sunset.
- Austin is the only city
in the United States
that still has functioning moon towers.
Before the moonlight towers
were put up around town,
it was dark!
The moon could only do so much.
And so it really changed people's lives.
I think it allowed them to keep
businesses open after dark,
which would increase commerce.
People could enjoy themselves
with friends and family,
and also get home safely.
Moonlight towers were
the only game in town
for light after dark, you know,
in parallel with the
moon itself, of course.
- And these towers clearly work
because, well, look at
me, I've got a shadow,
although admittedly I am
standing right next to it.
The name moonlight towers
isn't just poetic.
31 of these towers were spread around
what was then a much
smaller and lower city
before skyscrapers came along.
That meant that except
for some dark corners,
most of the town would be lit up
as if there was a full
or maybe a half moon.
Not that bright,
but enough that you could
see your way around.
Hence moonlight tower.
It's artificial moonlight.
Although, turns out
there's not much evidence
for that name being used
until the mid-20th century
when historical preservation
became fashionable
and these towers became an icon of Austin.
- They were not called moonlight
towers from the beginning.
The Austin newspapers just
called these "the towers".
There were no other towers.
First reference that
I found in a newspaper
to these being called moonlight towers,
it was 1938.
In the early 1960s,
the masthead of the Austin newspaper
had the phrase, "As Austin As".
The phrase changed each day,
where the newspaper was comparing itself
to other icons in the city of Austin.
And in July, 1962, the masthead said,
"As Austin as Moonlight Towers".
They have become a symbol of Austin.
- And every holiday season,
one of those moonlight
towers in Zilker Park
gets used to put up hundreds
and hundreds of bulbs of lights
that look like a holiday tree.
And you go and you spin
around and you look up
and you get dizzy, and
you feel like Austin
is just the best place to be.
- There are modern
versions of these towers
for places like giant parking lots.
Sometimes it is just better to
stick a big light on a pole.
In most cases, though, modern lighting
is a much better choice,
because every street got
wired up to the grid anyway.
Although that does mean
in the 21st century,
it's difficult to imagine what a city lit just by
moonlight towers would feel like.
These days there's too
much other light around
from every house, every building.
On a night with low cloud,
the skyglow from light pollution
can be brighter than
the old towers would be.
At least, brighter than they
would be at a distance.
These aren't street lighting anymore.
They're historic artifacts,
kept running because, well,
because the people of Austin like them.